so last time we have talked about
um cover number so cover number is upper
Bound for the rather marginal complexity
and then our goal is to bond cover
numbers because this is a new tool for
bonding around the market complexity and
we have discussed what are the bounds
for linear models I didn't show any of
the proofs but there are some existing
bonds which are 20 years old actually
and we also talk about the ellipses
Ellipsis composition number for carbon
numbers which is um much easier than the
uh the corresponding level for random
marker complexity so basically if you
know
a function class has good copying number
bonds and then you compose it with
Ellipsis function then you still have a
reasonable covering number bounds
um so so that's the the general idea and
then today we're going to talk about the
Deep new Networks
and we are going to use some of these
tools because you can see that a
deepness is actually composed of
multiple linear models with you know
some of the ellipse functions right the
activations so so this is the
uh the goal of this lecture so let me
set up the
actually sorry let me give me one moment
I think I probably have to change the
mask because I'm always having the fog
I don't know what happens with this mask
let's change one
maybe there's some efficiency with the
mask
okay let's continue so
so we have
um a new network so the setup is that we
have some Network that's called H Theta
Theta is the
is used to denote a set of parameters
and
um and we have all layers so the network
looks like this so the last layer we
don't have any activation and then you
have some activation in the next layer
you get a minus one
some connectors
so basically you if you do the
ordering of the math mobler formula so
you first multiply x with W1 and then
you pass through a nonlinearity and then
you multiply W2 and you do this so and
so forth until you have all layers
the system Network so there are layers
and wi are the weights
and the kind of the bond that we're
going to talk about is that so so here
is the theorem
so assume
uh x i
2 Norm is less than
C
and consider a family of networks with
the H Theta with some Norm control
of the weights so we control the
operator Norm
of the ways to be copper I
Kappa I
and we can show
the two to one Norm of wi transpose
to be bi
and then suppose you control your
complex function class like this then
the rather Markle complexity
will be less than
um up to constant Factor
uh C over square root n
times the product of Kappa I
times
the sum of
this is a complex formula let me explain
it in a moment
right from 1 to R
3 over 2.
so and
are alternative play you know
as a Corollary
I guess this is not necessarily that
formal because you have to talk about
you know what exactly this is you have
to have some failure probabilities
but you know roughly speaking you are
seeing that generalization error is less
than
or to the
1 over the margin
times 1 over square root in
times this uh times C
times the product
of the operator Norm
times the
this quantity
I guess here I'm using the
right so times the norm
this is a little bit okay anyway so so
so basically the important thing here is
that the complex damage depends on few
things one thing is that the operator
Norm
of the
of the weight Matrix and it depends on
the operator Norm as a product so the
complexity in the complexity term it
shows the product of the operating Norm
of all the weights shows up in the
complexity and also there's this term
which basically you can think of this as
a polynomial in Kappa I and bi so this
you can in some sense think of this as a
polynomial
of Kappa I and bi which is not really
important right so as long as polynomial
for for us you know it's not that
important because the product of the
operational Norm probably will be the
dominating term and that the polynomial
in bi in the cup I probably are somewhat
kind of like
and we write it very small so so so so
so we don't necessarily have to care
about exactly what this 2 2 3 2 3 means
actually they don't have any special
meaning it's really just something that
comes out of the proof
um but as long as there are polynomials
we are relatively happy with it
um and so so basically this is the the
important term and this term
um if you look at the bond it comes from
the lipsyness of the model so so copper
I is the bound on the ellipselessness of
a single layer and the product of copper
I is the bound on ellipsislessness of
the product of all layers
so
um uh so so so so so so so so so
without you know any details I think the
this term you know you can imagine this
comes from some ellipses composition
some use of Lupus composition level
we're going to see
this this is assumption sorry
this is I
thought oh you assume it's true for
every eye
I think this can be relaxed a little bit
again it's not very important so you can
maybe relax it to be the average of x i
is less than C it's not super important
one oh right so that's a yeah sorry so
the operator Norm is the
um I guess maybe I didn't so this is the
also the spectral Norm also the largest
single so
this is the spectral Norm
oh the largest
singular value
if any of this makes sense to you
and if uh and also the formal definition
is just that
the max over X
foreign
objects because this is the if you think
about WS operator then this is saying
that how does this operator change your
Norm right so if you give it a two Norm
Vector then how does it uh change the
norm
um yeah so
cool so and you can kind of see that
this is kind of like about Ellipsis this
is also maybe I should expand this a
little bit so this is also about the
luxiousness
foreign
model WX right because if you carry the
lepsis you know what you have to verify
you have to verify that w x minus Wy
is less than some constant times x minus
y
and what that constant should be right
so
um if you prove an inequality then
you're gonna get
the operator Norm
or spectral Norm of w there so that's
why this is the corresponds to the
Ellipsis needs of a linear model
foreign
Okay cool so by the way I have I haven't
got any questions from Zoom for a long
time so you should feel free to ask
questions just um
you don't have to but of course so
um feel free to animate yourself
um and
okay so how do we prove this so um
so uh the fundamental idea yeah so in
the next 30 minutes we're going to talk
about this proof
um the the fundamental idea is that you
um somewhat kind of cover your function
set iteratively
so cover this set of functions so I have
iteratively
and iteratively means that you you cover
more and more layers
gradually
and
um and and how do you do this
iteratively you have to use the
ellipsislessness
and sometimes the love just composition
the amount that we have discussed and
also you want to also control
and also controlling
how the error propagates
right so that's so that's a high level
summary it's kind of abstract but let me
um let me dab dive into the details so
for example let's say let's let's cut
Also let's try to abstractify
just for each layer of f
is f i so so basically f i corresponds
to
a linear multiplication a matrix
multiplication plus activation layer
right so this is a one layer and then
you can write F then you can consider f
as
this composition of f r with f r minus
one
so and so forth right so basically for
every layer we have certain choices you
can choose your weight Matrix and then
you compose all of this function class
by this composition I guess we have used
this notation multiple times this is
really just means that you're looking at
uh FR composed with f r minus one
composed with F1 where each fi is from
the family of capital f i
Okay so
um so this abstraction will allow us to
kind of have much cleaner
um
um notations but fundamentally you can
usually just think of each of the ifis
as an ISO layer right so and and and
what we know is that you know so we know
so suppose maybe let's say
so for the sake of kind of like uh
preparation so suppose
for every Earth in f i f i I've played
Wi-Fi in capital F5
FR is copper I ellipses this is actually
the case for us because you know we
restricted the the spectral Norm of of
the operating Norm of each of the Ws to
be less than copper I that means that
every layer is copper ellipses right so
uh and the value is one left just so
even you compose with activation it's
still a couple options so suppose you
know each of these functions is copper
Ellipsis then you know that you know
um
f i x so this these are just some
preparations
so two Norm is less than copper I
x minus y two Norm
and maybe that's just for Simplicity
suppose
fi is 0 is equals to zero this is also
the case you know in the in the real
case we care about when you have like a
network so and and also let's suppose
that x i
is less than C this is also our
assumption so then with all of this then
you know that uh we know a bunch of like
basic things so for example we know that
uh you can
you can bounce
what's this
was the material application of on XI
what's the normal
was the bound on the norm here so the
bound on the norm is can be bonded by
each time you make and most capture a
copper I factor so you get Kappa I times
Ka minus one
times couple I minus two so and so forth
times Kappa 1 times C
so
um
so we call this
CI
and let's define this should be equals
to CI so basically for this is some
basically kind of like a preparation so
under this abstraction you know some
bound on each of the layer and you know
each of the layer is ellipses
and
um what we're going to do is that we're
going to uh do two things so
for two steps
so first you control
the cover number of each layer
of each layer
and second
you have a combination element combine
you compose this you know like a combine
them
together
like a
so like you have a line that turns the
each layer right so you turn each of the
layers so you have a line with a
different single layer carbon number
bond
uh to multiple layer
not really
so
um
and I think number two is the number one
is kind of easy because for number one
this is just a linear model composed
with Zone lips just activation right one
left just activation you can just invoke
on the what we have discussed last time
right
um
um so so basically the important thing
is that how do you turn a single layer
carbon number bound into multiple layer
on carbon number bond that's basically
uh the main thing I'm going to discuss
so let's call this there's a Lemma that
does this so so
um
under the assumption
setup
above and the kind of like the
the relatively
um abstract setup above so assume that
supposed to assume
for every inputs
was
L2 Norm
less than C or minus one
uh so this inputs are used to define the
used to
Define
right the ol and LPN and the metric l2pn
so this is the the inputs value for
which we are evaluating your covering
number right so if you to Define cover
number you have to define the metric
Define which empirical inputs you're
evaluating on right so I'm assuming that
for every input of this Norm constraint
you have a carbon number
you have a cover number but
so you know that
Epsilon I
f i
L to p n
is less than some function
of this and CMS 1. some function of the
norm and some function of the target
radius
so this is just assumption this is your
simulator so basically this is assuming
that you have a single layer bound
single layer bound scene
so suppose you have a single layer of
carbon number bond like of this form and
you do have this Bond it's just that
didn't give you the exact formula right
so if you instantiate on a linear model
you are going to get something like this
this will be something like CM minus 1
square over Epsilon square right the
norm of the input squared over Epsilon
square right so that would be what
happens when you have linear models but
suppose you have the single layer carbon
number bond then
the conclusion is that you can turn this
into a multi-layer carbon number bond
and and this the form of this you know
translation is not very clean but
um it's like this so
and there exists the apps on cover
of I've R composed
up to F1
uh
for Epsilon is equals to
the following thing
that's right oh one more let me finished
okay foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I'm assuming a generic thing here um but
actually you can
just follow for the abstraction right
like you know when you really use it for
linear models it's going to be something
like CMS one square over Epsilon Square
so
um right so
this is G
um and then such so so there is existed
apps on covers such that with this size
such that
the log size
is bounded by the log size of this cover
is bounded by
sum of
G of Epsilon i c here minus 1.
and I from 1 to over
so so basically if you have a low carbon
number bound of this form for every
layer then you can have a low carbon
number bounds for this for this thing
uh and the bonds is the the law covering
number just add up
in yourself
but the tricky thing is that it's not
like a
um the the the cover size also grows so
the cover size also kind of add up in
some way which is a little bit kind of
like complicated
so basically your cover size is kind of
like multiply it's kind of added in some
way where you also multiply some of this
kind of like
in some sense and your cover covering
number is also added in someone
so this is the fundamental mechanism for
us to turn a single layer bond to
multiple layer bonds of course we are
going to I'm going to use this in some
way at the end so that we got the final
result because you have to choose what
apps and I's are right So eventually
what you do is that you're going to
choose epsilonize so that you get the
desired Target radius and you you work
out what exactly this formula should be
when for that particular choice of
epsilonize
does that make sense so far right so
um but before doing that I'm going to
first proof this lemon and then I'm
going to undo the derivations right so
after you have this this is the core
right after that this is just a choose
parameter so you just choose absolize in
some way that is in favor of you and and
work out what is the final block
foreign
so
I mean sometimes the interpretation of
this Lemma is that you know you somehow
you can add up the the covering number
bound the log cabin number Bound in this
way
as long as you pay some additional
radius like um
okay so this proof is in some sense you
know in one
in some sense it's actually pretty
simple but but the exposition you know
requires some some challenge like it's a
little bit challenging
so so the fundamental idea is the
following so
um so we start with this uh data point
um we start with this uh
concatenation of ended up ones right so
you have ended up ones and you map these
n data points to
a set of ports right this is the queue
that we talk about
I mean I think I need to draw this you
know good way so that
so that I I have more space so let's
start with
you start with endpoints and you map
these endpoints into a vector of
Dimension n
or maybe a um actually it's a matrix of
Dimension so
so you map this to
some space and each of this point here
is the concatenation of xfx1
up to f x n
and this is the so-called Q the set of Q
right that we have to cover
right so and you can use multiple
functions F right you can use f
any function F1 in F1 right to to map to
a different point
if you choose different f1s you want to
map different one
and if you just have one layer what
we're going to do is that you're going
to cover this set queue right that's
what we do for copy number for one
function for one family functions F1
right so
um
right so so then what you do is that you
like I'm just basically reviewing what
we have done for carbon numbers for one
family functions you you create this
kind of like
balls right so that covers it
so basically you create
um like the sensors
and these are points that are in C
right maybe let's call it C1 so let's
create some let's say C1
is Epson one cover
of f y right this is what what that
means right so and and now we are going
to see how do we turn this into a cover
for F1 composed with F2
so that's that's kind of the job we are
trying to do and and what's really going
on here is that you know for every Point
here
in in this uh in this uh in the output
space of right so this is the maybe
let's call this q1 which is the
the output space of
maybe let's call this thing capital X
so then
q1 is the family of outputs
where the function has to be chosen from
Alpha
right so and what's the what's the
composer so how about you know if you
have F2 another layer so what happens is
that for every point in Q q1 you can
apply multiple different functions right
for any functions little F2 in capital
F2 you can apply it to map to a new
point in the uh in the new space right
to map it to Newport so you got a for
every Point here you get a bunch of
possibility possible outputs and for
every Point here you get another bunch
of possible outputs right so each of
these new Point could be uh your image
after applying two layers
right so so now we are trying to apply
we're trying to cover this new set of
fun uh of outputs that are Q2 let's say
and how do how do we cover it so the
approach that we are going to take is
somewhat kind of like a
um
in some sense you know pretty Brute
Force what you do is you say you want to
leverage the existing power for Capital
F1 in some way so what you do is you say
uh you look at uh a center here in C1
and you look at what other image of this
point
uh in the in the Q in the in the after
applying a second layer so you get
something like this
right so this is the set of the image of
the output
or like of this point so maybe let's say
suppose
this point is called
F1 X
which is in C1 that's called this F1
primax which is in C1
and then you look at all the outputs
from iPhone primarks so you got this uh
family of points where you apply F2
on F1 Prime X
and where F2 can be chosen arbitrarily
from F2
okay so and now what we do is that we
cover
this set
by a new Epson cover so what you do is
you say
I'm going to cover this
with a with a bunch of things
and what does that mean that really
means that you choose a subset of of
capital F2
and and cover because here you are
ranging over all possible functions in
F2 right so if you want to choose the
cover for it you just say I'm going to
drop some of them I choose a subset a
discretization of capital of capital F2
so that's basically
uh the approach so and
and you you do this and you and then you
do this for every possible points in C1
and cover them so basically suppose you
have another point in C1
here and then you look at all of like
as image and you do another set of cover
and you do this for every possible point
in C1 and every possible points in C1
have induced a set and that side can
induce a cover and then you take the
unit of all of these right balls into
um uh and that the unity of all of its
right balls becomes a cover for the for
the Q2 right for example suppose you
have
let's say
F1 prime prime X here
right then maybe I should use a
consistent color
let's say you have a
F1 prime prime X and this is mapped to
the set of points
here this is the set of all F2 F1 prime
prime X
where F2 is in capital F2 and then you
create a cover
for this set
so that you can discretize F2 again
and then you take the unit of all of
this red cover of this white balls as
your cover for Q2
so so any questions so far
so formally what we should do is the
following so
um
so Epson one and Epsilon are
are the
radius
uh on each layer
these are just pre and which are TBD you
choose this you know I guess in this
level they are not TB they are just
already given to you eventually you'll
choose something uh I'll choose some
numbers for them and then what you do is
that
C1 is the Epsilon cover
Epsilon cover
of F1 that's easy
and then you say that for every
F1 Prime in C1
construct
this C2 a cover
in the second space
and by this cover depends on F1 Prime
so to cover to Epsilon 2 cover
the set
F2 composed with F1 Prime
which is defined which is what I wrote
above right this is F2 F1 capital X
uh
F2 is ranging in capital F2 right so for
every set like this where this set is
this
this side is really literally this blue
things that I drew here like this blue
side
and I come I choose a cover
I already know that cover to be C2
comma F1 Prime because this cover
depends on F5
and then I'm going to take the Union
so I'm going to uh
like C2
to be the union of all of this C2 F1
Prime where F1 Prime is in C1
so this is how I do how do I construct
the cover for the second layer
so so this is uh this is supposed to be
a cover supposed to be a
a cover for
Capital F2 composed with capital F1
okay any questions so far
so so there are several questions right
so one question is that you know what's
the
how good this cover is right that's one
thing and the other thing is that how
large these are discover this cover is
so the side the side of this cover is
relatively easy to compute because you
are basically just blowing off the the
size multiplying because for every one
in the olds in the C1 you you create
this cover right so you just multiply
basically the covering numbers together
in some sense and that's easy because
you you can formulate what you can do is
that you can say C2 F1 Prime
this is something the log of this is
going to be bounded by G of Epsilon 1 C2
uh sorry Epsilon 2c2
but this is Epsilon 2. this is episode 2
C1 I think in my location
C1
below C1
this is my assumption because my
assumption is that as long as your input
is bound by C1 and your cover size is
Epsilon 2 you have for this Bond
right so and also so that means that uh
the size of C2 is bounded by the side of
C1 times this exponential of this G of
Epsilon 2 C1 because for every point in
C1 you have
you have a bond for that particular that
corresponding set so then you just
multiply by C1
and that means the log of C2 is less
than the log
of C1 plus G of Epsilon 2 C1
which is equals to G of
oh Epsilon 1 C 0 plus G of Epsilon 2 C
1.
oh I guess actually I forgot to Define c
zero c0 just for convenience let's
define
right so
Define c0 to be just a c the the bond on
the input see so c c i's are the bonds
on the the the the the layers the
activation layers
um and c0 is the bound on the inputs
right so
okay
so you know so the so basically the size
is added up the log size is added up
that's easy and we're going to deal with
the covering how does the covering works
like uh at the end
um so so so before doing the covering uh
Computing a carbon radius let's define
how do you proceed with you know more
layers so similarly
for given
CK suppose you have covered K layers
then now you are constructing a cover
for the K plus one layer so what you do
you say that so for any
FK
Prime composed with
FK minus 1 Prime
F1 Prime in CK
uh
you construct
some ck plus one
which is a function
of this FK up to F1 Prime
so
uh that
Epsilon K plus 1 covers
the set F K plus 1 composed with
FK Prime
so I knew like this
CK the final color to be the Union
of
uh
of all of this kind of sets
and
similarly you can prove that the log of
the CK Plus One will be less than the
sum of all the single layer covers
Epsilon K plus 1
c k
plus up to G of Epsilon 1 C 0.
all right so so I've shown you how to
cover it it's just the iterative cover
that
kind of pretty brute force in some sense
and now the question is why this is a
good cover right why what's the radius
so basically we need to answer the
question right so so for every
f are composed
up to F1
which is belongs to this FR this set
right this is the site we're going to
cover so you pick a function in this set
and you want to say that this can be
represented by something in the cover
right with some small distances
so how why how does that work so you
first say that
you you know there's six As One Prime in
C1 such that
row of F1 F Prime
this is less than Epsilon y that's
something you know because C1 is a cover
uh Epsilon cover of the capital F1 so
now you have to say let's say you try to
pick
something in C2 that can cover F2
composed with F1 how to do that you
basically in some sense use the
uh use the construction you say that
um
maybe I should I should
I should draw this a little bit more so
okay so
so the first thing is it's suppose you
have you have a function here you have a
point here which is F1 of x right so you
cover it by this point
so how do I do this
let's cover this by this point right
so now suppose you have a point in the
second layer suppose you have a point
uh somewhere here
which is the map
which is computed from that f1x right
you apply some F2
to it
so and what you do is you say that you
first look at the Neighbors in the first
layer so you got this point
and this point you you look at uh
what's the neighboring
what's the image of this point
in a second layer maybe something here
so I guess here you're applying I guess
let's assume you're applying F2 here so
you get F2 here you use the same F2 on
the on the on the cover and you get this
point and then after you've got this
point
um
you you look at the neighbors the
in the right
see so you got this one so basically
this will be the cover
for the purple ones
I'm not sure whether this makes sense
sounds good
okay so in other words in more formula
so basically you say that
so you want to say there exists a
function in this cover right
in this C2 F1 Prime
so this is the this one
this one is
at the right point I think
this is that right point so you can
discover such that
such that
I have two rho of F2 F1 Prime is close
to what is close to
this move the blue point was the blue
point the blue point is F2
composed with F1 Prime
you know this is less than Epsilon 2.
right so
yeah I guess
I guess maybe let's write this as F2
Prime composed with I from Prime so
that's just to make it looks kind of
like wrong you know that's my that's
also what my cover is doing right so so
suppose zero F2 Prime composed with f
prime prime
so your cover has this structure that
you will first apply from Prime menu
cover you use the F2 parameter cover
right so
suppose
start what I'm saying here okay sorry
sorry my bad
so
so you have this function in this cover
such that
so
this is of the form let's say F2
I want to make this too complicated but
I think let's say this is of the form F2
Prime composed with F1 Prime
which is in this cover but this app this
one actually implicitly depends on
depends on
F1 Prime as well but let's uh Let's
ignore that notation so you got a row of
F2 Prime composed with F1 Prime which is
close to F2 composed with F1 but this
point is not what you really want to
cover because you're going to cover F2
composed with F1
so what you care about is that rho of F2
Prime composed with f Prime
the difference between this and F2
composed with F1 so this is the thing
you really care about
and you can see that there's still some
differences because the differences come
from that the
this is F1 Prime but not on F1 so that's
why you do a triangle inequality you say
that the target
is less than
row of
two prime
uh
composed with F1 Prime
so use this as the intermediate term
right so this one is less than Epsilon
2.
and you are left with this thing that
where you only differ in the first layer
right that's the difference you and but
this difference is kind of like
propagated in some sense
if you look at this figure this figure
is a little kind of like cheeky so this
is the difference in the first layer but
once you apply this this F2 right so you
have a bigger difference
so this is the difference in the second
layer
and this difference can be kind of like
a blow up a little bit because even
though you apply the same function you
may blow up the differences a little bit
so that's why you have to use the
lipstickness to say that this is less
than Epsilon 2 plus
Kappa
Kappa 2 times Epsilon 1.
or maybe covers 2 times
row of F1 Prime F1 and this is the
less than Epsilon 2 plus Kappa 2 times
Epsilon
that's how you bound the
the covering the radius for the second
layer
any questions
and you can similarly do all of this you
know in the
um
for 4K which
so there exists a function of K Prime
which depends on you know
One Prime up to f k
minus one prime
and in this set CK let's write this as
FK Prime composed with
K minus 1 Prime
composed with f Prime
and such that you know this is a
cover
such that the distance is less than
Epsilon okay
that's the Epson k
that's the definition of the cover
and then you have to kind of like
see why this is uh
a good thing for the original one where
you call that this is not actually what
you really care about you care about the
FK composed with FK minus 1 up to F F1
you don't care about the prime so you
care about this
this is the thing that you really care
about
you want to show this is small and how
to do this you kind of like it kind of
expand this into multiple terms
so you say that this is less than
so guys you
the first thing is you first compare
with
this kind of telescoping sound is pretty
actually useful in many cases
it first compared with this and then you
come compare
you just gradually pay off you know more
and more terms
this is no Prime here
and then until
finally you got
everything is kind of no Prime basically
and eventually you get
what you care there is no problem at all
so so this is just triangle inequality
and now you bound each of these terms
the first term by definition is less
than Epsilon K and the second term
s
the second term you see that these two
are the same
and this part is also the same
the only differences come from the
difference between this FK minus one and
FK the F Prime K and F are F Prime
commencement and f f k minus one so so
because of the cover that give you
absolute K minus one and and then you
also have to blow up a little bit
because of the FK composed on top of it
so you also have to pay Ellipsis needs
of FK which is a Kappa k
pop up
hey sorry McCain copper looks probably
almost the same
so
and then you have Epsilon K minus 2
times Kappa
K minus 1 times Kappa k
so and so forth until you have you know
in the last time you only the only
difference come from the first one so
you play Epson one because they are
Epsilon cover F1 Prime is from the Epson
cover and then you you pay a lot of flip
systems like half car park K times K
minus one
up to Copper 2.
so and and if you take k tobr then you
get the eventual thing right so the the
eventual theorem is that your radius
for the final
covering is something like
where is it
oops
still really is for the final covering
is something like this
right so that's eventually what you got
any questions
distance
so guys the question is that why
why you only have to why don't you only
approve require this
this is because like you know
suppose you know suppose
let me let me try whether this works
suppose your function class is like F1
composed with a fixed function
maybe in the other side so
F2 com F1 composed with a fixed function
that is called F2 maybe composed with F3
so and so forth fr and all of these are
fixed
then you only have this term
but this you also have to cover the the
possibilities for for the second layer
the third layer so and so forth that's
why you have to pay the other things
Okay cool so now we are done with this
Lemma and now let's go back to the proof
of the theorem
and approve the serum as I kind of
alluded before it's pretty much just the
kind of annoying
calculation in some sense
um there is a way to do the calculation
in a simpler way but I'm going to first
show you a zero knowledge proof so
basically I'm just going to tell you
that I'm going to choose my Epson y to
be this and and it just works out and
then I'm going to show you some some way
to kind of
but at least what I would do with this
you know if I write a paper I'm going to
show you the first proof I'm going to
show which is just a just choosing some
app so high so if let's start with that
so so basically
uh everything is about choosing Epsilon
I right so you first okay of course you
first know that this
for is equals to all tilde of CM minus 1
square
bi squared over Epsilon y score
um because this is linear model this is
linear model
composed with
one Ellipsis function
right so recall that each of the FI
is a linear model composed with the one
Ellipsis function a fixed one Ellipsis
function and and for the linear model
the carbon number the log cover number
is supposed to be something like the
norm of the input
and this is the
bi is the
wi transpose two to one Norm right so
the the norm of the parameter and
divided by the radius
this is what we have shown the last time
like we didn't prove this but this is
the Lemma we had last time about the log
covering number of the linear models
right so and so we'll plug in this and
then basically
uh uh
so basically you have two quantities
right so one is the logs carbon size
which is the sum of
CM minus 1 square bi squared over
Epsilon y squared
and also you have another thing which
which is a radius
which is uh sum of
Epsilon y I'm writing it as some Kappa
I plus 1 up to couple R right from one
two
r
right so you basically have these two
things that you want to trade off you
want to find the balance dependencies
between them you want to make the lower
common size to depend on the radius as
as best as possible
so so you just choose some apps right
and so the so you care about the best
kind of trade off all the dependencies
so that's this is absolute so so what
you should do is that you should say I
guess
if I give you a zero knowledge proof I'm
going to choose
[Music]
Epsilon I to be
C A minus 1 square
bi Square
over copper I plus 1 up to Kappa r
a third
times Epsilon
sum of b i
2 3 over
Kappa I two thirds
product of copper I 2 3.
all right
so if I choose Epsilon y to be this
then I'll claim that
sum of epson y Kappa I plus 1 up to
Kappa R this will be indeed equals to
Epsilon
and and why is that I'm going to do that
this tedious derivation for you but you
know I don't feel like you should really
need to verify it on a fly or you don't
necessarily have to verify it later but
just for the sake of completeness let me
do the calculation
this will be
[Music]
oh this is uh
uh you're just plugging Epsilon here so
you get a
I think CA minus one two thirds bi two
thirds this come from these two terms
and then there's some
thing about this and this
uh and also this thing right so you can
organize those things into or I guess
I'm only
I guess I'm treating this as a constant
for the moment
in this derivation so I got this
multiply with this we got two thirds
of I2 thirds
anyway if you don't want to verify this
just maybe
bear with me five seconds
all right so
I'm still
and then I guess one thing is that CI is
also a function of copper I because we
recall that CI is the norm Bond
for the layers which depends on copper I
question uh yes
the I here
this is the same eye
uh oh sorry you're probably yes you're
right you probably should use a
different index just for the sake of yes
so so if you want
uh I think even I read this it's
probably
okay right you know what I mean but at
the deal you probably is a j just for
the for the sake of
um
um completeness so yeah but but this one
will you average out this part like the
the after doing the salmon product the
eye is gone in the second part
so
anyway so let me
to the studio thing so we call that CI
is the norm bounds for so and CI is
defined to be I think CI is definitely
some product of cup ice and so we got
uh I guess let's put bi in the front and
then you got Casia is Kappa One Two
third up to
I minus 1 2 3. this is this corresponds
to
CR minus 1. and then you get copper I
plus 2 1 2 3 that's from here
but this is couple plus one I plus one
sorry
and then you still multiply the same
thing here
this this is
and then you simplify this
to
the first assume to
I guess you can see that the only
missing term is copper I so this is
equals to bi to third over Kappa I to
the third times Paradox of Kappa I two
thirds and from 1 to R
and times this thing
and now let's deal with this thing you
can see that this one cancels with
this one cancels with this one and this
one cancels with this one so you got
really equals to Epsilon
and the log covering size
is equals to
um
what is equals to uh the sum of the
um
what I'm doing here is equals to this
base quality the sum of
goodness first right attributing this is
CMS 1 square bi squared over Epsilon y
square and you're plugging up some y
here so you get this gigantic thing
maybe let's call this thing Z
so you got one over Z Square
times this one's sums of C minus 1
square bi Square you plug in this to the
minus two so you get
uh
CMS one square BMS one score
minus
two thirds
and then copper I plus 1 up to Copper I
2 3 and there's some cancellations
so this will be
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I think this
what
I think I I jump a step in my notes so I
okay I I I need to so sorry
I think you you you you plug in the
definition of cm and S1 then you get bi2
third over copper I 2 3.
times for product
of copper I
to a third and now I use the definition
of Z which is this gigantic constant and
eventually I think you get
let me now do that
that carefully but eventually you get
this
over Epsilon Square okay so I guess
maybe this is a good demonstration of
why I shouldn't do this right like like
even after I even had I verify this with
my notes which has almost all the steps
is kind of tricky so so but anyway so
before talking about how to do this
better
I guess let's first I agree that this
this is done right because now you see
the log covering size is bounded by this
Epsilon Square something over Epsilon
square and that's what we wanted to have
and then you apply the random marker
complexity apply the rather macro
complexity
the the the the the the tool from carbon
number
provider micro complexity recall that if
you have log covering number
it's R to R over F Square then this
means rather Markle complexity is
something like square root R over n
right so so this is what we discussed
last time and if you apply this small
tool then you get the log the radar
complexity will be this one
uh um square root of this one and and
overscripted and then you are done
Okay so
okay so so we are done but uh I think I
want to kind of share how to do this a
little more easily without going through
all of this pen
um this is a small trick it's pure
mathematical trick
um I I don't know how many of you know
it maybe maybe you all knowledge or
maybe you all don't know it
um but anyway let's let's talk about it
so basically the question is you care
about
right this is the question you can't
remember the trade-off between these two
so
and you care about the trade-off between
these two and
so what you could do is that if you
abstractify this it's kind of like
So abstractive speaking
this is about the trade-off between
something like AI maybe let's use some
different numbers say
Alpha I
score
over Epsilon I
Square versus sum of
beta I absent y something like this
right that's kind of the game you are
dealing with and how do you do the
trade-off I think
so what you would do is that you
use this uh
so-called holder inequality
so the whole inequality is that you know
there are multiple ways to write it for
example you can write a in a product
with B
is less than the P Norm of a times the Q
Norm of B when p
and Q satisfies this
right so and
for example when p
and or you calls already like this the
sum of a i b i is less than
sum of AI to the power p
to the one
this something like this
all right this is just exactly the same
same thing and the guys when p is two
this is the culture inequality and we
need something slightly different we
need piece
3 where Q is three over two
then you got sum of a i cubed
a third times sum of b i
2 3.
is larger than sum of a i b i so in some
sense you know all of these inequality
is trying to kind of deal with
um has this kind of form
and
I guess maybe what should I which one
should I do first
uh
like I'm not sure whether I'm I'm lost
in you so like I guess what eventually I
want to do is the following maybe let me
just give you an overview eventually I
want to do is just that I want to do
this
I'm going to say that this
product with the sum of beta I abs and Y
this is larger than
some of alpha I beta I
to the two thirds
and three two
so if you if you're able to do this then
you kind of like cancel out
so maybe sorry maybe let me do this
first so we care about sum of alpha I
square of absence I squared versus sum
of beta I Epsilon and this is your
absolute and this is your covering first
the covering
and what you want what you can do is
that you can say this
times this
Square
still forgot about this just let me do
it formally so
is there's an inequality that shows that
this is larger than
sum of alpha I beta I
the two-thirds over 32 and this is
essentially hold the inequality let me
let me justify this in a moment but
suppose you believe in me in this then
you say that and and suppose you also
believe that this is achievable suppose
we believe that equality is achievable
which I will justify in a moment
so if we call it is achievable
it means that there exists epsilonis
such that
sum of alpha I Square
Epsilon square is equals to this
quantity
32 over sum of beta I Epsilon y squared
and recall that this
is your Epsilon square and this is your
log cover number
then you get log cover number you can so
you get that you can choose
absolutely such that the log cabin
number is less than this which is equals
to this quantity over Epsom Square
and this quantity is your what you are
looking for
right this is the the r thing that
you're looking for which is the
something like this
and and you don't have to do any of this
verification right that's it and
basically just have to plug in Alpha and
beta and you just verify and that's it
so
does it make sense
so so basically you cancel all the apps
on eyes you know you try to find the
best apps by proving the best inequality
you want and you also want the inner
quality to be achievable
so
um so so for example another another
situation that this is used for is that
for example you probably have seen this
kind of font like you you have a
parameter ETA you have the ETA plus b
over ETA you want something like this
and you can choose your ether arbitrary
arbitrary so how do you do it you know
many people tell you that you just find
out the minimum ETA by doing some kind
of like uh taking a gradient right so
and you find out the minimum eight right
that's that's fine but so but my way to
do it is I just prove that ETA plus beta
ETA this is larger than two Times Square
b
this is conscious word so like AMG and
whatever you call it and this inequality
is achievable right you can attend the
equality so that you know basically the
best thing for this is two square B
asically basically if you know this is
equality inequality is
um
is is attainable then you know that you
can choose the existed ETA such that
ETA plus b over ETA is 2 square B and
then you get rid of the ETA you get the
best Bond you want so the same thing
it's the same logic here as well where
you prove the inequality so that you can
cancel out the parameter that you want
to choose and then you know and if that
equality that inequality can be attained
as equality then you know that you are
getting the best parameter and you don't
you don't even necessarily have to
compute what if that's why
or you know of course you know you write
a paper probably you still want to
complete Epsilon I and do the zero
knowledge proof right that's why all the
papers show you show you the these kind
of things uh right so because you know
so how do I
like I have to do a lot more arguments
right to show that this but but in your
mind you probably should do this later
version this is
later version you know at least this is
what I did in my mind when I do any
research like this but because this is
so fast so that you can get a
get a estimate on what the what's the
boundary can have right so
and in some sense this is useful
um
in many cases because you know one of
the way to make your theoretical
research
faster is that you have a lot of
modularized small steps which you can do
very very fast
right so so one of the way I found that
people can get into this
very messy calculation is that this you
know every Theory you know if you prove
something hard right so you have to use
a lot of pages right so you like your
eventual product is something like so
the page is proof or maybe more than
that sometimes there are 70 Pages proofs
or like 100 pages right so so
at least I I think at least in when I do
those kind of like proofs I never really
kind of like if I change one part of it
I never have to redo that 100 Pages
calculation to know what's the final
outcome so so basically after a certain
point I already know that in this part
maybe these two pages are the most
important thing I also know that how
does this page
translate to the final outcome and I've
already done those kind of very fast I
have a kind of like a very fast data
structure so that I know that if these
two
if this part can be improved by a factor
of two then what does that mean for my
final outcome and and that part is kind
of like already
abstract enough so that you have this
very fast conversion and then then you
can iterate very fast
um so so and and
as a
um the the flip side is you know the
like the this is opposed to another
model which is that you you change your
proof in some part you have to redo all
the other parts and so so that would be
much slower so so this is one of those
kind of this kind of tricks that I I
realized that so so if you can do
something small like this kind of
abstract things very fast and you can
iterate faster uh in your in your
research anyway so
so so far it makes sense and and if you
really care about why this inequalities
is true
why this is called is true I think I was
trying to just specify why it's true
because you can just use holding quality
I guess if you apply the holding cost
you get something like this and this is
still not exactly like this I think so
or actually this is exactly like this
right because you have to choose
you can choose your AI to be
you just say
IR Cube maps to this and b i
lab students if you just want to verify
right you just have to change it right
so but again you know if you want have
to verify this you know by matching it
it's still too slow to me so what I do
is I also memorize other different
versions of this holder inequality so
that I can do it faster I think the
version I memorized in my mind is that
at least one version of the holding
recording in my mind the mmrs is this
which is
something like
sum of UI Square
times 1 3
of the sum of VI
2 3
is rather than some UI
v i 2 3.
something like this which is even closer
to here right because in some sense in
sometimes the way you to memorize is
that if you have a bigger component
exponent here too then these two will go
to the vi
how do I say this so basically you put
the
select so why this is UI to the power to
three right so why this is UI to the 2 3
this is because here is you have a
square and then you you have a one-third
outside and the reason why here you have
VI to the power 2 3 is because you
inside you have VI the linear term and
then outside you have the two thirds so
so if you know that then you know that
if you have a square here then you can
cancel this Epson y because Epsilon y
will be squared and here you have
Epsilon Square so they can cancel each
other I'm not sure why this makes any
sense like it it takes some probably
some practice if you see this enough
times you know what kind of inequalities
can prove
um
anyway I guess I probably should wrap up
this discussion it's um
um any questions
okay I think let's see
10 minutes
foreign
this inequality because the equality can
be achieved so that's why
you know is the best choice oh you need
a final one okay yeah maybe let me
discuss that I'll answer that in the
next 10 minutes
right okay so so basically um now next
we're gonna do something more
um
better than this so and and actually it
turns out the proof is actually cleaner
uh to some extent
um because in some sense because it's
capturing the right quality so
so next we're gonna have generalization
bonds
that
uh
depend on the
actual level
s
and I'm going to argue that deluxedness
we had before was only upper bound right
before we have this
right before we have this right so
before we have
expand where you have
essentially a dominant term times other
terms
which is just polynomial in the
in the norm
which is not very important and this one
this is only upper bound
on the laboriousness
right and it's a pretty worst case upper
bound because you know you have to if
you really want your network to be
um to achieve this electricity you have
to actually like uh
kind of construct something that is kind
of like somewhat kind of like special
and even this is achievable right so
this worst case you know upper one can
be achievable in certain cases still you
want to find out the network which is
you know probably better in that there's
empirically so so so so that's why we
are going to kind of have replace so
basically the kind of the high level
goal is they want to replace this
product of the spectral Norm by
something that is more
um uh more of uh accurate and there are
many several motivations to do this so I
guess one thing is that um and this this
relates to the limitation of this Bond
so one thing is that this wi Opera Norm
uh has to be
louder than one or even you can arguably
say this is even larger than Square two
to make sure
FX
is not too small
right why this is the case this is
because if you look at every layer let's
say h i
is the ice layer
differential iPlayer
then h i plus one the true Norm of it
is the true Norm
of you know this
you apply this last layer and if you do
a heuristic you say that you know
suppose you believe
that this activation is value activation
kills half of the corners I see
right so so it is zero out half of the
chords suppose you have that kind of
like then it means that after value your
Norm will reduce by one over Square two
because you kill half of the chords
so
of course this is a very heuristic this
is just a belief right like a you know
assumption
um and suppose this is the case and then
you say that
um this is less than R score two times
the opposite Norm of
wi times h i 2 Norm
so then you can see that each time you
can only grow
your Norm of h i by this Factor
so if W I open a norm is less than
square root 2 then you are shrinking a
norm over layers
so your Norm of every layer will become
smaller and smaller and eventually they
will convert to zero so your output will
be very small
so so that's why you have to make sure
that the Opera Norm of wi to be somewhat
big it cannot be like too small
well you know in the most ultimate case
you know I think you want the Optimum to
be larger than one but in in its kind of
more typical case you need it even to be
larger than square root two so you have
the case right so so
um so so this means that
so in sometimes this means that you know
this the the product will be will be big
so and and another thing is that um
so motivation too I think this is
something I I mentioned right so this is
only a worst case upper bound it's it's
very worst case
of the ellipsislessness
and in practice you know
um so the so the lipsin is the
ellipselessness on the data points
the love justness
on the data point
X1 and UPS to X and
might be better
all the ellipticness on the
the population distribution or maybe on
the data points or maybe on the
or on X from P from the population
distribution could be better
right so and and this phone doesn't
capture that
and another thing is that
um it turns out that we will discuss
this you know in a later
um
lectures
um so it turns out that sud prefers
a flight locomi
this is something we widely believed and
in certain cases we can prove this and
the flat local mean
it's roughly speaking we will we'll show
this you know we will justify this in
later lectures but roughly speaking this
is
like the lapsiousness
of the models
only empirical data
so you can see that this is not a
luxiousness the worst case solar system
is on all data points is deliciousness
on the empirical data so which further
justifies I probably want to have a bond
that depends on Ellipsis on the
empirical data but not the
ellipselessness in the worst case
so and
and in some sense and also another thing
is that another remark is that it's okay
to to have a generalization bond that
depends on the empirical data so okay
to make the generalization Bond
depend on in private on
that's one after accent
because and in some sense this is
actually you know
nice because suppose
a generalization
is less than some function
of
the classifier and X1 up to excellent
this is still useful because you can
still use this
use it as an expressive regularizer
so there's no problem that your
transition Bond
uh there's no problem for our
generalization bond to depend on
empirical data you probably don't want
optimization bond to depend on
the population data because you don't
know how to regulate it anymore but if
it depends on empirical data it's fine
so so so basically concretely
uh in the next lecture I guess we'll
prove that
next lecture
we'll prove that the optimization error
the or the test error the L of theta is
less than some function
of the lipstickness
of f Theta
on X1 up to x n
and then the norms
of theta and this function is a
polynomial function which doesn't have
anything or exponential in it
okay I guess I'll uh I'll stop here any
questions
and interestingly the proof for the next
lecture is actually easier than today I
hope I don't know how do you think about
the proof today like
you know it's pretty brute for so in
that sense it's actually not very hard
but it's pretty messy
okay I guess so I will see you uh next
week